[Speaker 1]: Okay, today, Today is the 28th of January,
2026. So it is the 28th of January, 2026,
[Speaker 1]: yes. I have my section of papers, this is
the prior admission to hospital. But
[Speaker 1]: literally, I'm going to read the last
year's date. In your case, the 28th day
[Speaker 1]: ends on, ends on, it's on. So basically,
this is the 29th of January, 28th of
[Speaker 1]: January, 27th. This is the 28th of
January, 27th. if I leave, you know,
[Speaker 1]: because they are not abusing my rights to
housing and everything, but, you know,
[Speaker 1]: it's not really in their power to detain me
anymore, you know, because I've not, I've
[Speaker 1]: complied with the 8-day metric. So, this
is my story. So, it's basically, how long
[Speaker 1]: would I be here? You're kept for up to 8
days, up to 2. During this time, you must
[Speaker 1]: not leave unless your, let's tell you, you
may leave. uh yeah this is my therapist uh
[Speaker 1]: but you know if you try to leave the store
can't stop you yeah i still can't stop you
[Speaker 1]: the stuff with water it's not the stuff and
if you do if you do leave you can't If you
[Speaker 1]: were already kept in hospital under
section 4 of mental health act, then this
[Speaker 1]: time you would be in hospital for part of
the 8 days. So, section 4, not section 5.
[Speaker 1]: So, if I leave and I get brought back, it's
telling me if you were already kept in
[Speaker 1]: hospital under section 4, never of the
mental health act, then you would really
[Speaker 1]: be in hospital as counsel. And you do this
today. Um, she's not here until another
[Speaker 1]: day, but you know, I have to speak to
everyone. So, you know, I don't want a yes
[Speaker 1]: from them. Yes, Natasha, Natasha, if, you
know, Natasha, if, you know, because
[Speaker 1]: she's black in complexion, you know,
she's white, um, and I'm black, so, you
[Speaker 1]: know, I don't really care, because she's
got a, a cool set, because she's got a book
[Speaker 1]: down. But, you know, it's not, it's not my
position to live here. I have to speak to
[Speaker 1]: the other one, because, you know, they
work together, it's just two people, it's
[Speaker 1]: a two-people job, it's not a one-person
job. And this is why it matters, but, you
[Speaker 1]: know, it's not, because they have a bias,
so, You don't care. Because I can't define
[Speaker 1]: hate. I can't. I can't define hate until I
hate you. You see, I love you, but I don't
[Speaker 1]: love you. Because I can't define love
either. End of story. So, what else? Let's
[Speaker 1]: keep us in the frame of mind of a scientist.
Oh yeah. Brings me to the next point.
[Speaker 1]: Consensus matrix. Consensus matrix. So,
the consensus matrix is literally the
[Speaker 1]: sparse consensus matrix of love and hate.
Your love equals my hate. But, I think I'll
[Speaker 1]: write it down. Yes, this is my plan. So,
your love equals my hate. So, this is my
[Speaker 1]: plan today. to go out so it's a goal plan as i
showed them uh uh because hostel uh get a
[Speaker 1]: new car a better new car um nationwide
hostel well get dressed in rafa not red
[Speaker 1]: with raw money from my initial black
account and uh i'll go to council and
[Speaker 1]: request uh housing but basically i'm
reading this online but i'm looking like
[Speaker 1]: after now from third council so i can go to
third class directly or i can recover the
[Speaker 1]: online service um recovery service is a
crucial but speak to havering um uh and
uh
[Speaker 1]: I think that's very clear. Maybe I should
have stayed one more day. Because I've got
[Speaker 1]: to stay one more day. I should have stayed.
Anyway, speak to the hearing ahead of
[Speaker 1]: time. So basically, I'm going to have
housing in Arafat. But Dan, I'm not going
[Speaker 1]: to do it for you. but I've got a lawyer
involved in all this stupid nonsense but
[Speaker 1]: you know it's not it's not that he hates me
it's just that it's just how it is in the UK
[Speaker 1]: so the legal matter is I'm going to Nigeria
whether they like it or not you can hate me
[Speaker 1]: for it you can love me for it I can't define
that I'm not you I'm not you I'll never be
[Speaker 1]: you I'll never be you I'll never be no woman
like my mother no woman like my father you
[Speaker 1]: know because I've I've done enough for
myself I've done enough to get out of this
[Speaker 1]: situation or not I'll never be you so as I
said I do want to be detained, but, you
[Speaker 1]: know, I want to get housing, because I know
the system, but, you know, I've been in the
[Speaker 1]: rules, rules are not perfect, you can
break the rules, but that doesn't mean
[Speaker 1]: I've been in the rules. So, I'm going to get
housing in Romford now, but I'm going to
[Speaker 1]: have to try to get a lot of housing in
Romford via the Romford Council, because
[Speaker 1]: I want to be discharged from Romford
Council, but I have to call Thorough
[Speaker 1]: Council to be allocated housing, to be
discharged to Havering Council, because
[Speaker 1]: the housing is in Havering. my right to
call them. To call them. To call
[Speaker 1]: counseling. I've been this short. They
cannot say no to me on that anymore. My time
[Speaker 1]: has run out here. The time is very
important because it fuses out like a
[Speaker 1]: fuse. It fuses out. It runs out. It fuses
out means it runs out. It's like an
[Speaker 1]: implosion. The term I'm saying now is that
the consensus before I go to shower, I have
[Speaker 1]: to go by my consensus matrix. So you get a
9x9 consensus matrix, which is like a
[Speaker 1]: lattice space. So 9x9 is a different model
of a lattice. You get like a mesenchymal
[Speaker 1]: system of consensus. But there's some
things in 9x9 that you need. So the lattice
[Speaker 1]: is basically 9x9 because you've got 3 plus
3 human rights. You've got 9x9 is 81. So 99
[Speaker 1]: is 81, so it's 81. So 99 is the dimension of a
point in space where that point is a 1 or 2 or
[Speaker 1]: 3 that are related to give you some kind of
order via the lattice operation. So it's a
[Speaker 1]: measurement system because the lattice
has a 9 by 9 system. And that represents 81
[Speaker 1]: human rights. 3 plus 3, 3 times 3 is 9. 9
times 9 plus 9 plus 9 is 16. We have 15
[Speaker 1]: dimensions, 15 lattices. We share 15
lattices of the universe in dimensions.
[Speaker 1]: So 15 lattice dimensions that interact
with each other. Up, down, left, right,
[Speaker 1]: the dimension of space-time. via a mosaic
memory model. So it's a mosaic memory
[Speaker 1]: model that remembers you and covers you
into a system state. But basically,
[Speaker 1]: you're going to have to do a consensus
matrix to determine what needs to hold,
[Speaker 1]: and you don't have to hold that thing. So
for the system of what needs to hold, you
[Speaker 1]: cannot tell me what needs to hold. of token
type, token memory, token value, and
[Speaker 1]: token type and token kind. And the kind of
data there resulted in heterogeneous and
[Speaker 1]: homogeneous states of data. So I'm trying
to literally have a system for a
[Speaker 1]: metaphysical layer of So we don't have to
hold so much evolution as the
[Speaker 1]: meta-universe evolves. It's a digital
space, but it's a metaverse. So I call it a
[Speaker 1]: metamorphosis. It's not silly. It's a
metaverse. So it's a metaverse beyond
[Speaker 1]: living, which can be digitized via
quantum tunneling. But it's basically
[Speaker 1]: instantaneous because it holds the same
shared data within this physical reality
[Speaker 1]: and the mental reality of the mind. It's
basically an astral protector with a
[Speaker 1]: computer, with a divisor device. The term
hoarding refers to consensus hoarding.
[Speaker 1]: You need food, water and shelter. What are
the dimensions of food, water and
[Speaker 1]: shelter? Sleep is the bottom one. Do you
need sleep? Do animals need sleep? No. Red
[Speaker 1]: ants don't need sleep. They don't. But
black ants do. to operate, but, you know,
[Speaker 1]: red ants, I've never seen a red ant shut its
eyes and sleep, so I know they don't sleep,
[Speaker 1]: because, you know, I've been playing with
them as a child, for experimentation, but
[Speaker 1]: the red ants are literally the things that
don't sleep, don't need to sleep, they
[Speaker 1]: don't have that, so sleep is not needed in
their consensus reality of being an ant,
[Speaker 1]: so, you know, but, you know, the ant's
model is basically, you know, as we're
[Speaker 1]: human beings, so we can lose the dimension
if we don't have that model of consensus,
[Speaker 1]: because we need to eat, sleep, and poo, and
I need to sleep So it's basically how to
[Speaker 1]: protect myself into a state of being via
consensus holding, holding a kind of
[Speaker 1]: system of accountability. Because you
get a negative space where you share and
[Speaker 1]: you don't need it, you don't need to hold
it, which is rift triplet. So rift triplet
[Speaker 1]: is basically rift problem. Breathing is
not optional. Living is not optional.
[Speaker 1]: Only working is optional. So my love is
your hate. I cannot define, I cannot
[Speaker 1]: define, I cannot define I love to hate you
in my framework of Igbo man, my
[Speaker 1]: sovereignty. But these are terms that
intertwine. Because love is hate.
[Speaker 1]: Because if there's love, there's this
hate. And that's what you need to love.
[Speaker 1]: That's what you need to love yourself. I
love myself. I love me. O-B-I, which is the
[Speaker 1]: persona of me. I love me. Eze, which is
another persona of me. And I love you, me.
[Speaker 1]: Me, myself, and I. I love I. Uche. But this
is in the own reality. So these are three
[Speaker 1]: people that are called Namdi. When you
say, I love you, Nnamdi. No one said that to
[Speaker 1]: me before, and I'm very glad about that.
So, it is not a dystopian. It is a reality I
[Speaker 1]: share, and I have to manage with the
paperwork. But I love myself, so because
[Speaker 1]: I'm from Nigeria, I'm not British. What
I'm saying is, the kind of consensus
[Speaker 1]: matrix I'm inventing is 27. But it's 9 plus
3. 9 to the power of 3. not 19 straight
[Speaker 1]: because that defines the shared space
that needs to hold at the time and that's 27
[Speaker 1]: we don't need to hold 27 units of diameters
that which is lattice and it's mosaic so
[Speaker 1]: obviously it's color-coded it's
color-coded spins of quantum numbers um
[Speaker 1]: it's color-coded of quantum qubits that
determine the color of a solar system of um
[Speaker 1]: of non-linear no polarity uh because
non-polarity means that there's no
[Speaker 1]: sequence of instructions that's linear
and you have a pathway you don't have a
[Speaker 1]: specific definition it's called a system
that's not polar and it's non-linear but
[Speaker 1]: it's polar but it's not you cannot have a
non-polarity you have an inverse
[Speaker 1]: non-polar but you can have every unit you
move on but it's like a game if you don't
[Speaker 1]: know i'm saying it's like a video game so in
a video game you have ways you can go but you
[Speaker 1]: can have rigid controllers so you can in
that game, no glitch spot. So that's what
[Speaker 1]: prevents every pathway you should
perform, every path you go, every shape
[Speaker 1]: you take. If you become, if you've got a
quality streak, your quality doesn't
[Speaker 1]: glitch, and you can have a cooldown, and
you know, it doesn't matter what the game
[Speaker 1]: is, whatever you take is preserved, via
consensus is needed to preserve
[Speaker 1]: something that's basically and because
this is what you need uh permission
[Speaker 1]: requires authority uh but you need
permission there's no authority in my
[Speaker 1]: framework for it because you don't need
permission this is a one it's not an eight
[Speaker 1]: it could and should happen because it
could doesn't mean you should you should
[Speaker 1]: it should does not mean it would you have
would happen either so she could should
[Speaker 1]: would would you do it yes or no well could i
do it yes maybe would i do this and you go to
[Speaker 1]: wouldn't I do it? But that's the
permission of the Trident permission. So
[Speaker 1]: the permission has Trident model, three
models that you get. The consent. Could I
[Speaker 1]: have sex? No. I want sex. No. I need to have
sex. No. But the goal of this is to have the
[Speaker 1]: consent shared. And the only consent is
shared. So the consent of a peer-to-peer
[Speaker 1]: people, two people ask them, of a
peer-to-peer topology is a consent
[Speaker 1]: framework. So the consent is what the OB
contract is also, you know, consent to. So
[Speaker 1]: that's the OB-S contract. So
peer-to-peer or bus, which is like a...
[Speaker 1]: the bus topology, which is like the
topology of having a bus network
[Speaker 1]: topology. The indictment of a systemic
epidemic IP address them. IP address
[Speaker 1]: them. So IP address them is because it's a
concept of a kind of system of having the
[Speaker 1]: non-polarity boot sequence of OBSS. It is
defined. It's polar defined. But it's
[Speaker 1]: needed. It's consensus is needed. You
don't want that part to be there. It's just
[Speaker 1]: needed to have a response to that service.
It's not the kind of rigidity of computer
[Speaker 1]: systems in the framework of open access.
But the good part of open access is every
[Speaker 1]: part, way, shape, or form, there is a
solution to your problem because the
[Speaker 1]: problem is defined. to show your quantum
spin. And that's why that works that way
[Speaker 1]: though. It's not hard to do. It's just that
you have to find an array and give
[Speaker 1]: everything an array of quantum spin. No
matter if it's a spit and that person is
[Speaker 1]: really supervision and interference to
solve that problem so you can take any data
[Speaker 1]: you want um uh any data but you have to get
that rate to be non-rated so diary has a
[Speaker 1]: solution in a search space and that's the
person who has a tomographic which is an
[Speaker 1]: area over a pi pi pi over four pi over three
pi over two and pi for one which is pi get the
[Speaker 1]: system resolve itself tomographically
via the area of radium which is pi over 180
[Speaker 1]: and pi over 270 million times there's some
degree some angle pi of 180 times some
[Speaker 1]: angle like 45 degrees or 25 degrees and now
reserve the surface of the